quand je tiens une brique dans la
main je sais exactement de quoi elle est
faite et ce que je vais en faire
elle n'a qu'une seule forme et
fonction je dirais que ça m'apase en
quoi je peux vous aider je suis le
maçon monsieur c'est très urgent et
qu'est-ce que je suis censé voir
Victor on va devoir faire sortir V de sa
retraite qu'estce que vous voulez un VI
am peut pas passer vous saluer quelquun
de faire chanter la pour faire tomber
notre réseau à éelle Glob c'est pour ça
que je veux vous envoyer en Grèce pour
rgler ça avec
grosse mission pour vous prière fois sur
le terrain pas de superviseur c'est moi
le superviseur
bien
et maintenant on fait quoi je dois le
retrouver et en
finir tu aurais dû rester là où tu
étais maintenant que tu es de retour ça
risque d'être assez dur pour toi de
repartir on est
d'accord
je t'avais pourtant dit de ne surtout
pas t'impliquer tu pourras pas te cacher
éternellement je n'arrêterai jamais
jamais de te
[Musique]
poursuivre
oh moins de parfum la prochaine fois
d'accord très
[Musique]
cher
on part faire une chasse à l'homme et
pas construire une
cheminée désolé je ne travaille jamais
sans
[Musique]
outil